I know you got to go but I'm gonna ask
one more question okay cuz you have to
go but um so when you left the store
where did you go for those three or four
years seven years seven years I did the
Bray improv the second weekend but would
you go up at nights in LA anywhere
improv you're surely rogues
sorely missed I had to do that you have
to do that once in a while yeah
if you if you start in Ohio if you start
a columbus ohio and the guy likes you
you're gonna MC for two years then
you're gonna feature for about four
years and then one day he's gonna let
your headline Thanksgiving New Year's
Day yeah and then eventually you're
gonna get a weekend and then that guy's
gonna come to you and go after about the
seven year mark eight year mark he's
gonna look and go
you got a shit-or-get-off-the-pot you
either gonna stay here and be a [ __ ] a
Mook comic or you go that way I can't do
nothing else with you I had been at the
store from 97 from February 97 to
whatever the [ __ ] I disappeared yeah mm
I don't know six seven I saw the writing
on the wall yeah I saw it it was time
for Milli yeah I take sign from the
universe okay okay there's people that
don't see it sometimes I supposed to be
somewhere I got surgery I had a fat ball
in my neck that would get really small
II wanna come read rampaul Factory right
here they had a break my [ __ ]
collarbone only did to take the fat ball
out and when they took it a [ __ ] is a
fat ball I guess I ball of fat with no
cancer oh and the doctor came to me and
he goes do you want to see it I'll never
forget this nobody yeah I want to see it
and he brought it in a John when I
looked at it I go that's the evil from
The Comedy Store like you know when you
book a movie and you somebody comes in
he says congratulations Bobby you were
great and you walk away don't look at
the other guy go [ __ ] that [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ]
so all that [ __ ] that happens I felt it
there was a time when there was weird
people there they didn't like rogue and
was doing 45 minutes on Friday yeah
they didn't like they didn't understand
that he bought a sound system that dice
had bought a sound system they didn't
understand and I just thought it was
time to move on I just wanted to say
welcome back yes okay it's really good
to see you back it's good to see Joe
Rogan hold on let me tell you something
else okay let me tell you why I went
back why just so you know I work on
science I got the call from Adam on the
Friday that that [ __ ] still not Tommy
wasn't there no more and he was taking
over the store what I consider coming
back and I said I'll call you next week
let me think about it and I had a
colonoscopy that's when they stick a
cameo your ass and that night I stayed
up drinking that [ __ ] [ __ ] the [ __ ]
lately and you drink it and the movie
was on that movie with Peter Sellers
being their favorite and I watched that
movie and I said that's a sign for
Marilyn to go back to the store don't
leave yet yes no that's a true story
that was God that was God that was
Marilyn Malan was the one in her
deathbed that in the middle of the rant
in the middle of a rant about Jesus and
that if she got beat the cancer she was
wasn't gonna work dirty again in the
middle of the rent she stopped him
looked at me and she goes Joey you got
to stop doing coke and I probably
stopped three weeks later I went for an
interview for a movie and they told me
we really want you for this movie but we
understand you have a drug problem we
don't have a big budget I was so
embarrassed that somebody else knew
about my little secret I'm like I can't
do this no more and I was about 44 and I
read somewhere that John Gotti had taken
over the Gambino crime family when he
was 45 so I said I got to do something
when I'm 45 and I've been clean from
coke for ten years
there you have if God he could take over
get me those in 45 I had to do some of
my life 45 now would you know we do this
thing at the end where we do our God Joe
you get so most you got us almost yeah
bro we're talking this is home the heart
ear this ain't no [ __ ] okeydoke
podcast
I don't do podcast no that's why I'm
saying I call me okie I love you I love
you too
[Music]